.
>> TRIBUTES ARE POURING IN FROM
FOR MICHAEL K. WILLIAMS, WHO
PORTRAYED, WELL, THE ICONIC ROLE
OF OMAR LITTLE IN "THE WIRE."
HE WAS FOUND DEAD IN HIS
APARTMENT FROM A POSSIBLE DRUG
OVERDOSE.
JOINING US ARE TWO PEOPLE WHO
KNEW HIM ON AND OFF SCREEN.
HIS CO-STARS FROM "THE WIRE",
THANK YOU TO BOTH OF YOU.
THESE HAVE TO BE TOUGH HOURS AND
DAYS FOR YOU GOING FORWARD.
THE LINK BETWEEN THE PAIN, HIS
PAST PREVIOUS DRUG USE AND
PERFORMANCES, YOU CAN SEE IT
THROUGHOUT HIS CAREER.
YOU CAN SEE IT COMING ACROSS THE
SCREEN BOTH IN MOVIES AND
SERIES.
AND I WONDER IF YOU COULD SHARE
WITH US WHAT IT WAS LIKE WORKING
WITH HIM, HOW HE BROUGHT THAT TO
LIFE.
I'LL GO WITH YOU FIRST, ANDRE.
>> HE WAS ALWAYS FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY.
IT WAS ALWAYS ABOUT THE
HE KNEW A LOT OF PEOPLE DIDN'T
GET THIS OPPORTUNITY TO HAVE A
CHANCE TO SHINE BRIGHT AND DELVE
INTO HIS CRAFT AND SHARE HIS
CRAFT.
FOR HIM, IT JUST SPOKE TO HOW HE
WAS AS A PERSON.
HE WANTED TO MAKE SURE THAT HE
SHOWED PEOPLE THAT HEZ CAN SHINE
BRIGHT AND BE A GOOD ACTOR AND
ALSO A GOOD PERSON AND TAKE THIS
OPPORTUNITY AND HELP OTHER
PEOPLE.
FOR HIM, IT WAS ALWAYS ABOUT THE
OPPORTUNITY TO HELP.
>> I SEE YOU NODDING THERE,
SONIA.
>> YEAH, MICHAEL TOOK HIS ROLE
IN THIS BUSINESS VERY SERIOUSLY.
HE UNDERSTOOD IT TO BE A MISSION
AND A PURPOSE.
A PATH GOD CHOSE FOR HIM HE
UTILIZED THIS ART FORM FOR
SOMETHING SO MUCH GREAT THAN HIS
OWN BENEFIT.
THIS WAS A PLACE HE COULD TAKE
THE BRUTALITY THAT LIFE
SOMETIMES BESTOWED UPON HIM AND
TO SOMETHING FOR HIS CRAFT THAT
BROUGHT BEAUTY AND HEALING TO
OTHER FOLKS.
I JUST WANT TO OFFER SOMETHING
FROM OUR BROTHER WENDELL PIERCE.
HE'S REMINDED ME THAT MICHAEL
PORTRAYED TWO VERY ICONIC
CHARACTERS.
AND THAT IS OMAR.
AND WE REALLY DID BELIEVE IT.
THERE ARE FEW ACTORS THAT COULD
HAVE BROUGHT THE LEVEL OF
HUMANITY THAT HE DID TO THOSE
CHARACTERS.
AND THE ONLY WAY I BELIEVE HE
COULD HAVE DONE THAT WAS TO
REALLY INJECT HIS OWN SPIRIT
INTO THAT.
AND HE UTILIZED HIS ART FORM FOR
HIS OWN BENEFIT.
AND WE WON'T LOOK AT LGBTQ FOLKS
IN THE SAME WAY AGAIN.
THERE IS NO ONE THAT HAS BROUGHT
LIGHT AND AWARENESS AND NUANCED
PERSPECTIVES TO THE LGBTQ IMAGE.
AND WE JUST ARE GOING TO MISS
HIM DEARLY.
>> HE HAD ENORMOUS A ADVOCACY
OFF SCREEN AS WELL, USING HIS
FAME TO DRAW ATTENTION TO
CRIMINAL JUSTICE REFORM.
THAT WAS A BIG ONE FOR HIM.
AND "NEW YORK TIMES" QUOTES A
FRIEND OF HIS, WHO CALLED HIM A
PROPHET OF THE PROJECTS IN HIS
ADVOCACY.
I WONDER IF THAT RESINATES WITH
EITHER OF YOU.
>> IT RESINATES WITH ME BECAUSE
I MET MICHAEL IN '97 IN
BROOKLYN.
AND HE ALWAYS SPOKE OF HOW
EXCITING HE WAS TO GET A CHANCE
TO MAYBE WITH THIS NEW PLATFORM
AS FAR AS ACTING IS CONCERNED
THAT HE WOULD BE ABLE TO SHOW A
PATH FOR HIS BROTHERS AND
SISTERS OUT THERE IN BROOKLYN.
THAT THEY CAN HAVE A WAY OUT AND
HAVE A WAY TO BE HEARD AND BE
SEEN THROUGH THE ARTS.
OR STEPPING IN FRONT TO SPEAK
ABOUT POLITICAL ISSUES AND NOT
TO BE AFRAID BUT HE JUST SAW IT
AS A BADGE OF COURAGE THAT IT
DIDN'T STOP HIM.
EVERY TIME HE WAS IN FRONT OF
THE CAMERA OR AHAD AN
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK, HE WAS NOT
PEEK SPEAKING TO JUST HIMSELF.
OR DON'T HAVE A CHANCE TO BE
HEARD.
HE TOOK THAT SERIOUSLY.
HOPEFULLY, WE'LL CONTINUE TO
REMEMBER HIM FOR THAT.
>> MICHAEL REALLY UNDERSTOOD THE
VALUE OF SHOWING UP IN THESE
PLACES.
HE WENT THROUGH EXPERIENCES THAT
NEVER LET HIM FORGET THE PAIN
FROM COMING FROM THOSE PLACES.
AND HE UNDERSTOOD THAT HE WAS
PUT IN THIS POSITION OF POWER
AND HE HELD IT WITH SUCH
HUMILITY AND SUCH GRACE, BUT
ALWAYS UNDERSTOOD HE HAD TO
PHYSICALLY BE IN FRONT OF OF THE
PEOPLE THAT HE WAS REPRESENTING,
THAT HE WAS TRYING TO LIFT UP,
THAT HE WAS TRYING TO INSPIRE.
HE KNEW THAT HE COULD NOT STAY
IN HOLLYWOOD.
THAT'S WHY HE LIVE D IN BROOKLY.
THE PEOPLE WHO HELD HIM DOWN IN
HIS DARKEST DAYS, HE WAS LOYAL
AND HE WAS JUST THE BIGGEST
HEART THAT FOLKS JUST HE WAS
NOTHING LIKE THE CHARACTERS HE
PLAYED IN SOME WAYS.
>> HE WAS ICONIC IN FRONT OF THE
CAMERA, ICONIC BEHIND THE
CAMERA.
THAT WILL BE HIS LEGACY.
HE'S GONE WAY TOO SOON.
THANK YOU BOTH FOR BEING WITH